welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and after an
unbelievable month of back-and-forth
announcements
spider-man is officially back in the MCU
with the news breaking worldwide that
Sony and Disney have come to an
agreement thank God now today the two
companies announced that Kevin Feige
will produce a third film in the
spider-man Homecoming series that will
start Tom Holland as the titular
character this is coming from official
sources like variety deadline comic book
movie calm and the news is a cause for a
huge celebration the rumor mill over the
last couple of weeks has been ramping
that the two companies have been close
to a deal but we finally know that
spider-man will be back in the MCU at
Marvel Studios we even had it look like
Kevin Feige was moving to star wars
yesterday and in my opinion I do the
conclusion that this was the reason that
Sony wished to part ways I did do an
opinion video on it and hey it looks
like I was wrong I did say I'd be wrong
110 percent probably so yeah I was but
it's really good to hear that the
webhead is now back in safe hands the
new deal which was signed last night has
seen that Disney will receive roughly 25
percent of profits as opposed to the
prior five percent that they received
Disney will retain merchandising rights
and spider-man will also be available to
appear in other films in the MCU the
next spider-man film is scheduled for a
release on July 16 2021 and Amy Pascal
will produce the film as she did with
the prior two movies Kevin Feige said
today I am thrilled that Spidey's
journey in the MCU will continue and I
and all of us at Marvel Studios are very
excited that we get to keep working on
it as spider-man is a powerful icon and
hero whose stories crossed all ages and
audiences around the globe he also
happens to be the only hero with the
super power to cross cinematic universes
so as Sony continues to develop their
own spider-verse you never know what
surprises the future might hold now this
definitely sounds like venom is gonna be
in the universe as well as the Madame
web movie that was announced yesterday I
did a full breakdown of the
coming Sony's late yesterday so
definitely make sure you check that out
after this if you want to know more now
whilst it did say that spider-man
wouldn't be at Disney in that video I
did theorize that he would still be
connected to the MCU but I'm glad
everything's under the same umbrella now
Kevin Feige yesterday was also announced
to be moving to Star Wars and developing
a film there however it looks like the
studio head will also be heading up the
far from home sequel obviously I'm
ecstatic over the news and have pretty
much been riding firmly in the camp that
they will come to an agreement even
though things have looked really bleak
over the past couple of weeks I just
want to give you a huge thank you to
everyone who stuck with the channel and
all of the numerous updates
I've had several sources telling me that
things are closed throughout the past
month many people have called me a liar
download my videos and it got to a point
where even I stopped believing them
because of how bleak things looked so I
just want to thank everyone for the
support and for sticking with me it
really does mean a lot now how this will
affect the announcement of Madame web
yesterday remains to be seen but make
sure you say lock to the channel because
I'll be doing an update on this over the
next couple of days
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this news and if you're as
happy as I am
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out our top 5
list on the Jason Aaron graphic novels
that you need to pick up after Thor god
of thunder if you want to come chat to
me about movies TV shows games and comic
books that make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey
it's the best way to get in touch with
me and it's the perfect place to suggest
new videos and content so hopefully I
see you over there after this well so
just one let you know that we're
currently giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on
spider-man's return in the comments
section below the winner will be chosen
at random on October the 15th and the
blue arrow be shipped out from then to
forget surprise so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care
[Music]
[Music]